steht auf jeden Fall fest die Pandemie
ist noch immer nicht vorbei das hat der
Kanzler jetzt gesagt echt auf ihre
Lieblingsveranstaltung herrbruder auf
dem Weltwirtschaft und da sind wir
direkt drin Oktoberfest
in der Wurst kommen gerade die Mächtigen
und alle wichtigen Menschen dieser Welt
zusammen doch Henrik ein Bruder ist das
keine wichtige Veranstaltung im
Gegenteil im Gegenteil wissen Sie ich
wollte nur noch ein Wort zum Glauben und
Wissen sagen natürlich gibt es einen
Zusammenhang zwischen Glauben und Wissen
man kann mit dem Glauben anfangen und
dann wissen enden aber hier geht es um
mehr als Glauben und Wissen hier geht es
darum dass Leute angesichts dieser
Katastrophe die ist ja wirklich gibt
irgendetwas haben müssen was sie tröstet
und dieser Trost Übungen sind Überfluss
hier gespendet worden man hat in der Tat
leute Leute die kritische andere gemacht
haben wir Frank und ich und wir von der
Achse und andere die hat man zu Corona
leugnen erklärt und der Ursprung gemacht
guten Fuß stehen egal Themenwechsel
sagen
ich bin mal wieder nicht eingeladen
worden ich hätte gerne meinen
Migrationshintergrund in den Vordergrund
geschoben aber ich Greta war schon da
nun gut die hatte doch dass ich nicht
habe und jetzt gehen wir die üblichen
Spekulation oder das
Weltwirtschaftsforum deswegen nur ganz
kurz gegründet 1991 und 1971
Entschuldigung von Klaus Schwab denn
gebildeter Mann ist er hat einen Doktor
in Betriebswirtschaft und
Ingenieurwissenschaften und inzwischen
ist das hat die sogar die liberale
Situation geschrieben inzwischen das
ganze Form eine Gelddruckmaschine der
Apparat setzt 390 Millionen Dollar im
Jahr um ist ein Familienbetrieb geführt
geleitet organisiert von Klaus Schwab
seine Ehefrau und den beiden Kindern
also ein richtiges Familienunternehmen
mit 800 Mitarbeitern wenn sie auf die
Website des Wortes Forum gehen gibt's
eine kleine Selbstdarstellung unser
finden Sie den Satz committed to
improving the state of the world wir
verpflichten uns den Zustand der Welt zu
verbessern nicht etwa den Zustande
Nahverkehrsmittel Westfalen oder sowas
nein das muss gleich der Zustand der
Welt sein das ist halt die Sprache der
Leute die sich für Experten halten ich
habe eine Allergie gegen Experten
experten erklären einem heute was
gestern passieren musste aber sie nicht
imstande heute zu sagen was morgen
passieren könnte und sie haben diesen
riesigen Auflauf dort an Experten die
sich dort mit ihrem Wissen mehr oder
weniger präsentieren im Prinzip im
Prinzip ist das eine Art von Karneval
für die gebildeten Stände und die
wundere mich dass die Medien in diesem
Zirkus diesen zusammenkommen eine solche
Aufmerksamkeit schenken nur weil da
prominente Namen dabei sind und auf der
anderen Seite das ist mir das genauso
witzig entstehen wieder
Verschwörungstheorien dass das die
geheime Elite ist die die Welt lenken
also wenn das ein geheime Elite ist die
Welt lenkt dann kann ich nur sagen
Hessen sogar sind sie nicht und dann
sind sie noch völlig unbegabt
aber in der Tat hat das seit eine
gewisse Ähnlichkeit mit Corona der ganze
Zirk das ganze Verfahren ist ja
unglaublich so albern und so dumm wie
der Weltklima Gipfel wo die Leute mit
einem Jets angerauscht kommen und dann
müssen die Jets weiter fliegen bei den
Kopenhagen dürfen sie nicht parken es
war nicht genug
in diesem ägyptischen Dorf dessen Namen
nicht vergessen habe
weggeflogen werden also das sind reine
Fenster Schau Schaufenster
Veranstaltungen die nichts bringen und
wirklich viel kosten ähm was ich dann
noch dazu gerne sagen wollte zu den
Eliten das sind keine Eliten das sind
Leute die auf irgendeine Weise Erfolg
hatten sich durch große Leistungen nicht
auszeichnen das geht auch während
intelligentesten gehört ich habe mir
ausgedruckt welche Ordner bekommen hat
und man kann die Leute auch daran messen
ob ihr schon im bundesverdienst gehabt
haben oder nicht er hat inzwischen drei
außerdem hat er das große Goldene
Ehrenzeichen für Verdienste um der
Republik Österreich wahrscheinlich keine
Topfenknödel von milliampstrudel
unterscheiden er ist Ehrenbürger der
Landschaft Davos klein kein Wunder er
hat auch den Orden der Freundschaft
Kasachstan was ich am besten finde ist
der Orden vom aztekischen Adler in
Mexiko dann gibt es eine Liste seine
Veröffentlichungen hat neuen Bücher
veröffentlicht davon einige auch nur als
herausgegeben
sie heute gerne im kleinen Schweizer
Berg das natürlich sitzen sie am
liebsten in diesem Tisch davon gehe ich
auch
schön
würden Sie gerne in der wusste dabei
sein dieser Woche Bundestagssitzung und
da bin ich natürlich natürlich
teilweise die Kritik weil gerade bei der
Klimakonferenz hat man das gesehen da
kommen dann wirklich viele
Klimaschützer oder solche die sich so
nennen und genau
Gesundheitsminister CO2 in die Luft
geblasen und wenn am Ende nicht viel bei
rauskommt dann ist das tatsächlich
kontraproduktiv trotzdem ist es
natürlich grundsätzlich wichtig dass es
auch irgendwo Formate gibt bei denen
Staatschefs Regierungschefs andere die
in der Wirtschaft oder in Unternehmen
Einfluss haben auch miteinander sprechen
das würde ich jetzt nicht grundsätzlich
kritisch sehen aber es muss natürlich
was bei rauskommen insofern würde ich
immer dann sagen an ihren Taten solltet
ihr sie dann messen und wenn da was
richtig gutes bei rauskommt dann kann
man das hat sich gelohnt wenn das aber
nur eine ja Quassel Runde ist bei der
nichts rauskommt dann hat sich das Ganze
nicht gelohnt was ist das für sie eine
quasselhunde oder glauben Sie es kommt
was bei raus wenn so viele Menschen die
in der Welt großen Einfluss haben
zusammenkommen
erstmal keine schlechte Idee aber die
Widersprüche sind Patienten zu greifen
und humoristische zu nehmen ist wohl die
beste Art und Weise allerdings ich habe
es ernst gemeint stimmt entschuldigung
aber allerdings bleibt mir lachen dann
noch ein bisschen im Hals stecken wenn
ich mir zum Beispiel mal hören mit was
er da so von sich gibt ja er hat sich
dann mit den Leuten den Architekten auch
des corona-hypes getroffen zum Beispiel
Jeremy Fahrrad und äh fantasiert von dem
jahrhundert der Pandemien also sie
wollen das multiplizieren und das ganze
ging los diese ganze diese ganze Lobby
Geschichte ging los vor 25 Jahren mit
Corona Forschung und damit auch auch
gegen
mittelforschung zu den entsprechenden
manipulierten Viren und jetzt Frau
Schubert was glauben Sie denn wer das
Ganze vor 25 Jahren gestartet da wäre es
finanziert hat diese ganzen
corona-forschung und mRNA
impfstoffforschung wer hat das
finanziert so ich sind sagen
Friedenspartei was Pentagon gewesen ja
und das sollten Sie hellhörig werden für
was für ein Karren sie haben spannen
lassen und die machen nämlich da gerade
so weiter und das greift auch mein Thema
wieder auf wenn wir eine funktionierende
Arzneimittelsicherheit hätten dann würde
das nicht möglich sein aber sie haben
sie mit Corona geschrottet
wenn sie direkt darauf sie wurden direkt
angesprochen Frau Schubert also nach
meinem Informationen stammt wurde viel
Forschung für ein Krebs für eine
krebsimpfung gemacht und wurden
Erkenntnisse aus dieser Forschung
für für den corona-impfstoff genutzt ich
bin keine Medizinerin ich bin keine
Pharmazeutin ich kann das letztendlich
überhaupt nicht beurteilen ich habe mich
auf das zu verlassen was die Fachleute
im Auftrag der Regierung und sagen als
Parlamentarierin weil entstanden die
politischen Entscheidungen wir ja dann
als Parlamentarier auch zu vertreten
haben und dann werde ich mich in
irgendwelche verschwörungsmythen nicht
verstricken aber ich dachte jetzt geht's
eigentlich um um diese um den um Davos
und die Frage ob solche Formate sinnvoll
sind Klimaschutz steht ganz oben
Klimaschutz zu organisieren ich sag ganz
ehrlich ich finde es befremdlich dass
solche Treffen privatwirtschaftlich
organisiert werden weil wenn sich
regierungs-
finanzministerinnen und Minister treffen
dann gibt es da eigentlich andere
Formate in dem das sinnvoll ist also die
Vereinten Nationen die OSZE aber nicht
in privates Hotel oder ein privater
Wirtschaftsmann
das fände ich auf jeden Fall den den
sinnvolleren Rahmen deswegen teile ich
nicht die Kritik am am Klima Gipfel ich
glaube das ist notwendig ist dass sich
die die Regierung dieser dieser Welt
zusammensetzen und überlegen wie kann
man die Klimaziele einhalten weil
letztendlich steht die Zukunft dieses
Planeten auf dem Spiel die den großen
Kippung werden wir alle hier an diesem
also die vielleicht noch aber an der
Rest an diesem Tisch alle nicht mehr
erleben aber diejenigen die wir in die
Welt gesetzt haben und der Nachfolge die
werden Sie erleben und die verantwortung
heißt dass wir irgendwie in der
tatsächlich in allen Ländern an allen
Hebeln jetzt reden müssen oder ziehen
müssen um diesen Klimawandel zu
entschleunigen um einen anderen Vater
eine andere Logik einzuschlagen und
alles was da an Gesprächen gibt die
tatsächlich dann auch zu konkreten
Ergebnissen zu konkreten Maßnahmen
führen diese die sind mir sehr lieb und
sehr teuer weil ich glaube
nicht mit ich gehe da nicht mit es gibt
den Gefallen kann ich Ihnen leider nicht
tun ich gehe aus einem schlichten Grund
ich mit weil dieser wenn Sie so wollen
Kultur der treffen hat er nicht von vier
Wochen begonnen das gab schon vor 50 60
Jahren der Klappe from hat genau das
passiert sagen schon von 50 60 Jahren
veröffentlicht und gehen die Ressourcen
aus um das Jahr 200 2000 wird das nicht
mehr genug Rohstoffe geben all diese
utopischen und das distopischen
Vorhersagen sind nicht eingetroffen und
was den klimawandelalter würde ich jetzt
nicht weiterführen
es ist ein Horrorszenario das ganze ist
eine Frage der Religiosität je weniger
Leute an Gott glauben umso mehr Leute
glauben sie können Gott spielen sie
wollen das kriegen den Klimawandel
entschleunigen musste sich dann etwas zu
viel zu den Klimawandel entschleunigen
glauben sie vor uns hat kein Klimawandel
gegeben es hat immer Klimawandel
gegangen die Frage ist nur ob die Erde
bewohnbar bleibt oder ob sie zumindest
in Teilung unbewohnbar bleibt
von der mächtigen Politik hin zurück zur
Basis denn viele Menschen können ihre
Miete nicht mehr bezahlen und dieses
Thema gehen wir einfach nur kurzen Pause
hier bei 8:15 Uhr bleiben Sie gerne bei
uns